-Welcome to the launch zone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
Now, for this game, we're going
to play you a popular song.
When you think you know it,
stomp on your foot pedal
to launch your mic
in the air like this.
If you catch the mic...
-Whoo!
-Hands!
-...and correctly
name that song,
your team gets the 1,000 points.
It was a little slippery,
but I caught it.
If you drop the mic
or get it wrong,
someone else can buzz in,
okay?
Alright, now, round one
is called "One-track Mind."
The band will be playing
these songs
one instrument at a time.
When you think you know it,
get ready to launch that mic.
Here's the first song.
♪♪
-♪ Ain't no mountain... ♪
"Ain't No Mountain High Enough."
-Wow!
-Yes, sir.
-Yes!
-♪ Ain't no mountain
high enough ♪
♪ Ain't no valley low enough ♪
-They got to say the artist,
though.
-Respect right there.
That was fantastic.
-You got to say the artist,
too?
-You got to say the artist.
-No, you don't!
Friends, you're drinking, man.
I love that.
Let's hear another one here.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Did you freeze?
-Oh.
-Boom, boom, boom.
Play it again.
-Buzz him.
-I don't know.
-Oh!
♪♪
-"Don't Go Chasing Waterfalls."
-Oh!
Come on now.
-♪ Don't go chasing
watterfalls ♪
♪ Please stick to the rivers
and the lakes
that you're used to ♪
-That's a classic, my boy!
-And it's from Atlanta.
-Oh, my goodness. Oh, my God.
I'm sorry, TLC.
-Final song for this round.
Here we go.
♪♪
-"24K Magic in the Air."
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Laughs ]
-Had to make a comeback.
-That's 1,000 points.
It is time for round two.
This round is called "Trombone
Thugs and Harmony."
Our DJ will play
a popular hip-hop song,
but all the instruments have
been replaced with trombones.
Buzz in as soon
as you know the song.
Here is the first one.
-All the instruments?
-Yeah.
♪♪
-♪ Push it real good ♪
[ Ding ]
♪ Let's push it real good ♪
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
-You overthought it.
You had that.
I saw you.
You were like...
[ Humming ]
You were almost pushing it,
yeah.
-Oh, my God.
-Alright,
let's hear another one.
You ready? Here we go.
♪♪
-"I'm Sorry, Miss Jackson."
-Yes!
♪♪
-How, how, how.
-♪ Never meant
to make your daughter cry ♪
-You are for real.
Here we go.
The last one for the round.
Whenever you're ready, guys.
♪♪
-No. Hey!
-Dr. Dre, "Dre Day."
-No!
-No, no, no, no, no.
Give me that.
"No Diggity."
-No!
-Oh!
"California Love."
-Yes!
[ Ding ]
♪♪
-That's what I tell you.
♪ Buh-buh-deep-deep,
deep-deep-deep ♪
♪ Buh-da-deep, deep,
Not bad.
Guys, it is time for round
three, okay?
This is the final round
of the game.
And this is called
"One-second Wonders."
We're only gonna play you
one second of a song.
You have to guess what it is.
Are you ready for this?
One second.
-You got to back up.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's hear the first track.
♪♪
-"Hit Me, Baby, One More Time."
-That's correct.
-Okay.
-No, no.
That's not it.
-What?
-That's not it.
-Sorry.
"Oops, I Did It Again."
-That is correct!
-♪ Oops, I did it again ♪
-That's all good.
That's all good.
-You set me up, buddy.
You put me
right where I needed to be.
-That's right. That's right.
-You said the words
right there.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, let's hear
another one-second song.
Here we go.
-♪ It was all a dream ♪
-"Juicy," Notorious B.I.G.
-Yeah!
[ Ding ]
-♪ I used to read
"Word Up" magazine ♪
-We were all on the ship
that time.
-Help me get us back up there.
-♪ Hanging pictures
on my wall ♪
-Chance.
-I was back!
-My God.
Ready, guys? Here we go.
This is a tricky one.
Go.
-♪ Aye-aye-aye ♪
-Oh!
-I don't know.
I know the song.
-What's the song called?
-I don't know.
-♪ Aye-aye-aye ♪
-What is it? What is it?
-I forgot what it's called.
-Oh, he dropped the mic!
-He dropped it.
-He dropped the mic.
-"Crazy" uh...
"Crazy," "Crazy" "Crazy Train."
-Yes!
-♪ I'm going off the rails
on a crazy train ♪
-Yes!
"Crazy Train," Ozzy Osbourne.